It's never clear whether Boo’ya
Moon was always there,
whether it's a kind of alternate
world, an alternate reality.
Or whether it was actually created by
the ferocity of Scott
Landon's imagination.
Scott and Amanda both
have their dark sides.
They're fragile. They experience life
in the world in a pretty intense way.
Boo'ya Moon is both really beautiful
and a very scary place.
My character has to go to Boo'ya
Moon to draw my inspiration.
And she does too.
She's struggling. And that's
the place that she goes to heal.
Amanda is the one that really
understands both worlds.
She really can experience what Scott's
created in a very particular way,
and can navigate this reality with
this world of fiction
and of this fantasy.
Missus, I thought we
had an agreement.
Seems like you don't get how
serious this business is,
although I'd thought a dead crow
in the mailbox would be pretty
hard to misunderstand.
I'll be seein' ya.
F*** you, Jimmy.
Now, missus, that isn't a bit nice.